uh so so there's march of the penguins
so you always see like penguins huddling
together
against i i mean sorry if i see just
metaphors and everything but uh them
huddling together against the harshness
of the conditions around them that's
very kind of
that's like a metaphor for life like
finding this connection that's kind of
what love is it's like it allows you to
forget whatever the absurdity whatever
the suffering of life is together you
get to like
huddle for warmth and that's why i love
the uh sort of just the uh the honesty
and the intensity of the way penguins
just in the middle of like the cold do
this and then this video i saw
a lonely this is this is misinformation
so the name of the video is lonely
deranged penguin i don't know if he's
deranged so if you play it
so he left his pack
and uh and that there's a nice like
voiceover and you don't need to play it
but he for some reason left the pack
and journeyed out into the mountains
and so the the narrator says that he's
deranged he's lost his mind
now i'd like to project the idea that
he's actually
there's so many stories you could think
of he's returning to his homeland
he's an outsider thinking journeying out
into the unknown thinking he may be able
to discover something greater than the
tribe he might be looking for a lost
love
why is he deranged immediately why has
he lost his mind anyway but this people
should look up this video because to me
i might be the only one who uh
romanticizes this but it's such a nice
kind of it's both a picture of perhaps a
mental disorder which is what the video
kind of describes and it may be some
deeper explanation that's not
that that has to do with the motivation
of a
of a mind but perhaps yeah i don't know
if i don't know if you have a deeper
analysis on this penguin well i i
like you as a psychiatrist
i i would i would want to sit down with
the penguin and
then go through
i want to see the notes from his prior
therapist and
but
this this actually is is irrelevant not
knowing what was that penguin's
motivation we have
very clear
situations where there are both within
an individual we go through periods of
time when we
stay in one place
and we
reap the benefits from what we've built
and then we go through periods of
foraging of of of wandering even if
there may be resources where we are we
we
have periods of time in our lives where
we wander where we where we
go in an exploratory mode and different
people express that trait in different
ways
this is not a human specific trait if
you go down to to the tiny little
nematode worm
c elegans with 302 nervous system cells
they go through these phases of foraging
and rest and different individuals have
different propensity to forage or to
rest and stay in one place
at the level of the species that's
really good
that there's that
diversity in their willingness to forage
some stay where they are the species is
somewhat on a firm footing then
but some carry a burden
a risk for themselves but
it's good for the species that they're
explorers and they will venture out
the migration patterns that
different species blunder into and that
turn out to be really good they weren't
logically derived
they most certainly started from
something like this an exploration
humans do this to you think and we do it
too
in fact it's
something we do extremely well
you